to help our count will decide what to do
in a district we want to hear what you
think the question is simple do you
support shops opening for trading on
Easter Sunday I was for the elephants on
that one push meaning I feel there's too
much time screams in retail as those
fishes for our staff they here longer
and longer hours and Melissa time with a
failure in here a few days of the years
of the public holiday that everyone will
stop and taking a break from a business
perspective customers these days
expected to be here if you're not here
though they'll shop somewhere else so if
you want to be in me tell you if you
need to put the air I think would be
great to have the option and we restore
the open seven days a week and we find
that we have local coming in on us some
bones are really happy to see us open
they do understand a lot of substances
are owner operated and it would be
really hard to find that kind to the
heavy option would be great but I've
heard what they have to say what do you
think let's talk we can make your
feedback 9 on our website Facebook or at
any of our service centers if the
trading is just one topic covered in our
draft and your plan does it by my career
is what govt p thought in peace to find
out more and have your say
[Music]
you
[Music]